la represión sigue en Irán mientras las
manifestaciones entran en su tercer mes
en la provincia sudoriental de si están
balucci están las fuerzas de seguridad
abrieron Fuego contra los manifestantes
el viernes según los activistas decenas
de personas murieron o fueron heridas
tras la jornada de protestas las
manifestaciones fueron convocadas en
todo el país esta semana en Solidaridad
con el kurdistán que junto con el System
baluchistán ha sufrido particularmente
de la mortífera respuesta de las fuerzas
de seguridad el sábado el líder supremo
de Irán alejarmenei saludó el trabajo de
los basics una milicia islámica que ha
tomado parte en la represión del
movimiento vieron en estos asuntos
recientes que el pueblo perseguido de
basic se sacrificó para evitar que la
nación sucumbiera a la fuerza de un
grupo de asesinos Rebeldes analfabetos
esclavos se sacrificaron para evitar la
crueldad de otros según la agencia de
noticias de activistas de Derechos
Humanos
448 personas fallecieron desde el inicio
de las protestas que fueron convocadas
tras la muerte de masa a mini las
autoridades iraníes por su parte afirman
que unos 50 efectivos de las fuerzas de
seguridad murieron en las movilizaciones
este jueves el consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU voto por la creación
de una investigación independiente sobre
la represión de las protestas pero eran
condenó la medida y dijo que era inútil
y representaba una violación de la
soberanía nacional del país
[Aplausos]